our next presenter is the very essence
of stardom a breath of spring and the
scent of mimosa lifting our spirits
again in Robin and Marian you've been
away for too long
welcome home Audrey Hepburn
the nominees for the best picture of the
year ah Barry Lyndon a hawk film limited
production Warner Brothers Stanley
Kubrick producer Dog Day Afternoon
Warner bradley's Martin Bregman and
Martin elf and produces a universal
zanuck Brown production Universal
Richard D zanuck and David Brown
producers Nashville and ABC
Entertainment Jerry Weintraub Robert
Altman production paramount
Robert Altman producer and One Flew Over
the Cuckoo's Nest a fantasy films
production United Artists Saul Zaentz
and Michael Douglas producers
the winner is one
but the dream started at the Rialto
Theatre in Passaic New Jersey a long
time ago but now gratification comes
from all over the world in Japan
reporter said you must have had a grand
passion to make this picture and in
France director said you must be
fiercely proud and they were both right
what is gratifying right now is to know
that you share our pride and our passion
with us thank thank you must go through
a magnificent cast and crew to Kirk
Douglas who lived with it for 14 years
the people at fantasy in Berkeley to the
people at United Artists all over the
world and to Arthur Krim Eric Pascale
Mike Medavoy who became believed
believers the first moment of contact
with Cuckoo's Nest and my love to Dorian
Josh Athena and Johnny and dreams do
come true
I think it happened one night picture
1937 the last time a film one picture
director actor actress I just like to
really thank the Academy for all your
support and to our really incredible
cast and crew who I think we all learned
something about working Ensemble andis
all said United Artists the state of
Oregon and as Louise said really to
anybody who's got a dream and as
possibility is that it's not going to be
a reality just hang on
it's go alright let's go thank you